On December 31st, cities across the globe...
...welcome the new year in spectacular style.
From New York City's Times Square...
...to the ultimate dance party in Australia,...
...you're sure to find a destination for an unforgettable New Year's Eve.
Hong Kong ushers in the new year with an 80-minute pyrotechnic show...
... over Victoria Harbor,...
...and visitors can count down to midnight in the city's Times Square.
More than a million people gather...
....for the world-famous party in New York City...
...to watch the iconic glittering ball drop in Times Square.
Big music acts and lots of confetti...
...make this one of the biggest parties in the world.
Sydney is one of the first capital cities in the world...
...to greet the new year with celebrations...
...like fireworks displays in Sydney Harbor...
...and a massive dance party at Bondi Beach.
Chimes at Big Ben help bring in the new year in London...
...as crowds gather for an elaborate light show along the River Thames...
...during the city's three-hour extravaganza.